نحيكم مشاهدينا من جديد يواجه سوق
السيارات الكهربائيه في العالم العديد من
التحديات التي تحول دون انتشارها بشكل
الكافي في السنوات المقبله تقرير صادر عن
صحيفه
الى ان مبيعات السياره الكهربائيه في
الولايات المتحده ارتفع لنحو 66% في عام
2020 مقارنه بالعام 2001 2020 ووفقه
دراسته صدرت مؤخرا عن مؤسسه دوليه للطاقه
وتنميه المستدامه فقد اظهر انا مبيعات
السياره الكهربائيه في السنوات الاخيره
تزايد بشكلنا ملحوظه لكن رغم الزياده
الملحوظ في عدد المركبات الكهربائيه فهو
لا يعد عدنا كافيا للاحلال محل السياره
التقليديه بحلول عام 2035 ويبقى مراقبين
خصوصا ان صناعه هذا النوع من السيارات
سيزالواجه صعوبات في زياده طاقه تخزين
البطاريه للسياره بالاضافه الى صعوبه
الحصول على المعادن اللازمه للتصنيع
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نحاول فهم هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا
من بيروت وليد خدوري الكاتب العراقي
المختص في شؤون الطاقه سيد وليد اهلا بك
معنا حضرتك كذلك لك مقال في نفس هذا
الاطار وشبيل نقاط جد مهمه بعنوان هل
السياره الكهربائيه جاهزه لعام 2050 في
جريده الشرق الاوسط وتحدثت عن صعوبات
الصناعيه خاصه هل هذه الصعوبات سيد وليد
تعطل تحقيق الحلم الحلم
بالاعتماد فقط على السيارات الكهربائيه او
انها ستنسف هذه الصعوبات ستنسف تماما هذا
الحكم وهذا الحلم وهذا غير وارد
المشكله شنو انه تصير الانبعاثات 2050
ويبدا قبل 2050 من 2030 2035
ولكن لا توجد سيارات كهربائيه كافيه ينتج
عالميا سنويه مليون سياره كهربائيه بين
معانا الطرقات العالم اليوم تريون 400
مليون سياره عاديه
فلا يمكن لانتاج سيارات الكهربائيه
لماذا لم يحسب حساب ذلك
يعني هم 2050 على اساس انه الموعد الاخير
لتحسين مناخ العالم بعد الموعد هذا من
الصعب تحسين المناخ هاي هاي
لكن توجد هنا مشكله السياره في كل
التغير المناخ مثلا
نحن نستعمل في العالم اليوم
85% من الطاقه العالميه النفط والغاز
البتاع المستدامه من الشمس
بهذه الطريقه
والغاز 2005 في تسرع بالموضوع
اذكر اوكرانيا ايضا لي تصاحب الامور اكثر
وليد
المطروحه هو الى اي مدى هذه السيارات
الكهربائيه قد تكون الحل الحقيقي للمحافظه
على المناخ اسئله بخصوص طريقه توليد
الكهرباء كذلك
موضوع المناخ تبريد ال همم المنزل اللي
يعني التهويه
كثيره ليست فقط
وكما ذكرت انه العالم متاخر
ولا يمكن ان تحل البترول 250
فعتقد تصرع في قراره معنا
ولكن حتى افهم منك اكثر طيب البعض يقول
بان سياره الكهربائيه هي الحل
لوقف الانبعاثات وللي المحافظه على المناخ
ولكن لتوليد الكهرباء هناك طرق عديده ومن
بينها الاحتراق الكيميائي الانشطار النووي
وهذا قد تضر بالبيئه اكثر مما قد تضر به
او همم يزور به همم الوقود مثلا همم صحح
لي هذه المعلومه الى اي مدى يمكن ان تكون
فعليا هي الحل
لا هذا صحيح ولكن ايضا في تصنيع السياره
الكهربائيه عندنا معادن بس النيكل وبتلن
الجنين مثل النحاس هذه المعاني
تشغيل السياره
ولكن
2015 بباريس كانت تصريحات سياسيه اكثر
منها تصريحات واقعيه
طبعا قسمنا سياسي ولكن ايضا
انه هم يعني العلماء يقولون انه
اذا ما نبدا بتصفير 2050 لنستطيع مساعده
الكره الارضيه هاي نقطه مالتهم لماذا سبب
وضع عام 2050
لكن لا توجد مكانيات فنيه وعلميه اللي
تغير كل شيء بسرعه
نحن نلتقي في نفس النقطه انا ودت سؤالك عن
همم في حاله اخفاء الدول في الوصول الى
استعمال كلي او تعميم سيارات كهربائيه في
2050 الى اي نسبه يمكن ان نصل اذا ما
تجننت هذه الدول لتحقيق ذلك
يعني تخبل تخبل طبعا
بقوه ولكن لا ليس ليس تصفير
مثال بسيط الهندي الي ثاني دوله بالعالم
بكثافه السكان بعد السيد طبعا
تعداد السكان الهند برنامج
52 معناها
في فتره
العالم
الثالث
الكهرباء السيارات
غير متوفر يعني لا توجد اراده سياسيه في
معظم الدول ما عدا دول الخليج في الامارات
السعوديه الكويت الى حد ما هو مسقط ومصر
والمغرب
من المنطقه الشرقيه
الموعد المحدد للتصفير انا اعتقد في طول
عقود
لماذا حددوا 2050
لمحاوله تنفيذ كل ما قرروه في مختلف القمم
الخاصه بالمناخ لماذا 2050 بتحديد قلت منذ
قليل بانه هم يتوقعون بان بعد 2050 لن
يكون هناك المجال لذلك
هذا صح هذا العلماء
2050 صعب
طبعا
الامير عليه ممكن تخف الانبعاثات
جدا
مختص في شؤون الطاقه شكرا
على المتابعه والسلام عليكم